irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport en compagnie de guy
bourguignon
légumes oignons qui est allé là-bas
dites nous si ces premières images vous
replonge vraiment dans l'atmosphère du
pays
et bien d'après les costumes nous sommes
dans l'extrême sud du brésil au rio
grande et du sud patrie des gauchos et
idy gauche on dit chez valve hitman ya
une chose que vous saviez que au début
du xviiie siècle il n'y avait pas de
chevaux voici
sinon moi je sais très très peu de
choses et j'avoue que j'ai signé moi on
m'a raconté l'histoire les jésuites qui
avait créé l'émission pourrait enlever
lisez les indiens ont amené le cheval
avec ses chevaux se sont reproduits en
très grande quantité et ont formé dans
les pampas des manades sauvage des
hommes sont partis d'abord pour les
attraper ensuite pour les garder et
voilà comment aimer le gaucho maintenant
ce gaucho duras est transformé en
gardien de vaches comme le cowboy de
l'amérique du nord
m
voilà trois gauche ont ils mettent
pied-à-terre pourquoi je suppose que
c'est pour manger
vous allez voir quoi à votre avis que
sort de sous sa selle ce monsieur sa
gauche la tradition voudrait que ce soit
de la viande ou il c'est de la viande
en effet c'est de la viande qui a subi
un traitement particulier les rester
d'abord qu'un jour dans la saumure vie
après elle a séché au soleil comme elle
est quand même un peu sèche et un peu
dur on la met sous la selle pour
l'amortir un bon oui et ça va servir à
faire le plat national du gaucho qui est
le jour à ce qu le show asco vous mettez
cette viande ou la pitié dans un pieu et
vous la faites cuire au feu de bois est
derrière vous arrosez le tout vous
pouvez voir que ces messieurs doivent je
n'ai pas besoin de vous dire ce qu'il
boit limitée du mat et bien entendu
mme laguiller
le show vasco cuit se mange c'est
l'huile de la cuisson ce n'est pas à
nous le dira sûrement oui mais se mange
regard des biens commencement le show
asco c'est très spécial
essayer chez vous c'est très dangereux
c'est bon vous en avez mangé la main
j'en ai mangé oui mais dans les
restaurants de sang volo et doriot avec
une fourchette et un couteau c'est
infiniment plus prudent et oui qui
comprennent il ya des troupeaux qui vont
jusqu'à 3000 têtes de bétail à peu près
des normes et le soir comme les cowboys
de l'amérique du nord
on chante et on danse il y un rapport du
reste avec le cowboy de l'amérique du
nord ce qui concerne la gauche oh c'est
ce que je ne vous dirai pas d'où ça
vient et pour quelles raisons c'est venu
jusque là mais la danse qu'ils sont
entrain exécuté en ce moment n'a rien de
latin ça se rapproche carrément du
square dance de l'ouest américain du
nord
les hommes bien entendu son botté
gardent leur répond en les larges
pantalons qui s'appelle les bons matches
a souri ou de même des termes techniques
du prix ils n'ont pas ici le fond chaud
parce que le conjoint est une chose qui
ne se portent qu'un hiver ils ont pour
la plupart la pala est une carte
infiniment plus légère dans laquelle il
s'enroule pour dormir la nuit
je ne peux pas tout le temps le même
geste
oui c'est carrément le square dance
quand même chose c'est une répétition
vous l'assuré marché oui alors vous
devez vous demander pourquoi je vous
emmène sur un marché maintenant ne
croyait pas que ce soit pour parler
piment ou tomate et nous avons tout à
leur parler d'un plat national les
gauchos qui s'appelle le chou vasco je
vais vous parler maintenant
par l'intermédiaire de tous ces aliments
n'est ce pas la feijoada la feijoada qui
est un plat national brésilien
vous voulez la recette bien sûr alors
vous allez voir ils mangent la feijoada
ces gens là vous prenez une terrine de
terre vous l'entourer de couenne vous
mettez des rondelles de saucisson de la
viande fraîche du bbl de préférence
meebo bout et mettre aussi des moutons
des haricots noirs très important le hic
au noir de la tomate des oranges
beaucoup d bis et vous faites cuire vous
faites bouillir tout ça pendant des
heures et des heures à petit feu vous
dirai aux l'hiver si ça mijote ses
meilleurs s'est très vite elle s'est
très très épais comme ça ne suffit pas
etc semblent pas suffisamment épicé au
moment où vous le manger vous rajoutez
défi memphré et pour que cette colle
deviennent de la pâte
vous rajoutez de la farine de manioc
plaisante mais c'est très bon et vous en
avez mangé oui aussi décidément vous
mettez du risque pour faire passer je
crois oui cette machine italienne à
votre avis c'est pour nous amener sur le
café du brésil bien entendu je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure que six jeunes les
pas dit c'est une erreur les gauchos
boivent le mater sans sucre ni vous
allez voir que pour le café c'est
exactement l'inversé chaque coup de
sucrier correspondant à une cuillère
regardez vous même il ya très peu de
café dans chaque tasse la dame est
raisonnable
honda
5 quand vous allez me dire que le sucre
fond oui oui alors chez vous imitent de
le dire et alors grâce à cette image
savantes et à ce joli pas seuls deux
tasses nous allons arriver à la
plantation du café et voici une petite
partie d'une des plantations
ça s'appelle une phase n o brasil une
des plantations des plus importantes
celles de monsieur lunar daily mail ou
nardelli que vous voyez ici sur la
droite est un très vieux monsieur
le soleil et le café doivent conserver
un très vieux monsieur je crois qu'il a
85 ans quelque chose comme ça il a sept
fils 51 petits-enfants et 20 millions de
pieds de café oui c'est net c'est 13 mai
signe particulier ce monsieur ne sait
pas écrire et estime que c'est
complètement inutile d'apprendre étant
donné qu'il y a des secrétaires et qu'il
faut bien que les secrétaires travail
c'est un point de vue
ici vous avez la récolte du café on ne
cueille pas le café fruits par free on
prend la branche et on laraque enlevant
en même temps les grains de fruits et
les feuilles on ne les en effet tombé
par terre il reste qu'on peut prendre et
on ne les retient pas et après ça avec
des râteaux tout et anbar terre avec des
râteaux en ramasse alors évidemment il y
à un mélange et de terre et de feuilles
de branches et de ce fruit
alors il va falloir séparer tout ça
s'est très vite fait comme vous allez
voir et en plus de ça c'est fait avec un
geste très élégant on met le tout sur
des tamis très simple
aimer
et on joue
et voilà la terre d'une masse à travers
le tamis
le vent fait travail les feuilles et
seul le fruit reste dans tous ces pros
plus difficile que ça
geste est lui-même a droit au sommet
et moi
rêver café
je ne connais rien de pire
pour mai
mais
ça m'empêche de dormir
ordre est
et café
jusqu'au contre d'un ami
alors tout devient banal après n'est ce
pas le café le fruit du café mis dans
des sacs les sacs sont mis sur des
chariots traîné par des mulets et en
amène tout ça à la phase 1 dans la cour
de la fazenda ou en vie dans ta le fruit
du café alors on a beau quand même
l'avoir trier avec le tamis il reste des
brindilles de rugby ne dévoile ni danser
dans ses fruits
l on le fait glisser dans les cours en
vue assez rapide d'eau le grain va
partir vers le fond et les bruns d'yvon
surnager et donc le tri s'est fait
automatiquement
orthez
et c'est trop pour un seul
moi et je jouais pas
l'ombre
alors ainsi crié on va amener ce café en
plein air sur une sorte de plancher
le divorce n'est ni un plancher de danse
qui un plancher de volleyball ou de
basket malgré l'auront que vous voyez au
milieu qui a son utilité retenez bien ce
rond et on va étendre le café en couche
régulière
me des bords en jeu
le soleil valser chez quand les couches
supérieures sont sèches avec cette sorte
de râteaux on le ramène vers le cercle
le cercle indiquant la limite du café
sécher tg
demain
mon sommeil
une boîte
rêver alors vous voyez maintenant tout
le travail est fait donc tout ce qui
narre certes est infinie est temps sec
on le ramasse et puis alors c'est fini
ça devient et du café alors simplement
faire griller grillé sommes en jeu leurs
murs
or doigté
et café
je tiens à vous signaler que le café est
une plante itinérante en ce sens que les
caféiers au bout d'un certain temps me
demandez pas combien de tomes n'en sais
rien honnêtement je n'en sais rien ceux
détruits d'humeur et détruisent la terre
sur laquelle ils sont plantés ce qui
fait qu'il faut constamment bouger la
plantation la faire avancer
donc le travail et non seulement de
cultiver le café qui existent mais de
prévoir les nouvelles plantations
oui c'est tout cela finit cette route
c'est la route que l'on appelle la haute
du café qui va de san paulo à santos une
déclivité de 800 mètres vers la mer
santos étant le port du casque voilà et
c'est de là que de café par vers le
monde
eh bien merci infiniment guilbault
biniou et à la semaine prochaine pour
rio et son carnaval
m
antonio vous a proposé un voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
concours de guy beugnon de george p si
c'est le seul aspect terre script
nathalie de muret montage pierre michel
rey illustration sonore de nice gazelle